en 2020 nous vous avions présenté un
reportage sur le Bti le Bti c'est un
larvicide qui tue les insectes picaires
et qui est largement utilisé dans le
monde au Québec toutefois son épandage
pour des raisons de confort ne fait plus
du tout l'unanimité au sein des
municipalités et de la communauté
scientifique pendant ce temps
l'industrie mène une bataille féroce
pour empêcher Québec d'adopter le
principe de précaution dans le cas de ce
pesticides mais le vent a peut-être
tourné
nous sommes à Nicolet à l'été 2022 cette
municipalité utilise le Bti afin de
contrôler la nuisance causée par les
insectes piqueurs pour la dernière fois
[Musique]
on parle beaucoup de changés
comportement dans plein d'aspects donc
de vivre avec ces
moustiques là c'est nuisance là ça va
faire partie de l'adaptation que
l'humain va avoir à faire
[Musique]
la mairesse Geneviève Dubois reconnaît
qu'il n'a pas été facile de faire
l'arbitrage entre les citoyens
préoccupés par l'environnement et ceux
qui craignent de perdre une qualité de
vie acquise depuis quatre ans grâce au
BT
il y a de plus en plus de rapports on le
sait là je veux dire la biodiversité
l'importance de maintenir les espèces de
ne pas intervenir dans l'environnement
c'est là c'est c'est réel on travaille
pour les gens qui sont en place
actuellement mais si on essaie de
travailler pour les générations à venir
donc c'est vraiment dans cet esprit là
qu'on a pris la décision on a choisi
d'être prudent même si ça allait
décevoir plusieurs citoyens
dernièrement d'autres municipalités au
Québec comme la belle terre bonne mont
Saint-Grégoire et sainte Perpétue ont
aussi cessé le traitement au Bti
dans certaines villes c'est plus
compliqué
à Trois-Rivières par exemple la bataille
pour convaincre les élus ressemble
parfois à un dialogue de sourd
dire ce que j'ai déjà dit
à chaque fois vous allez m'interrompre
ça va être plus long le débat fait rage
au Québec depuis 2020
la Semaine verte avait alors réalisé un
reportage sur les effets du Bti sur la
biodiversité les insectes Picard nuisent
aux activités en plein air pour s'en
débarrasser il existe un produit le Bti
pour assurer le confort des citoyens et
garantir les activités touristiques le
Bti devient la solution préconisée pour
se débarrasser de ces insectes piquers
on y expliquait que ce pesticide est
biologique parce que la seule bactérie
qui le composent vit naturellement dans
les sols
[Musique]
depuis plus de 40 ans le Bti a remplacé
graduellement la plupart des
insecticides chimiques sur la planète
dans plusieurs pays il contribue à
sauver des vies là où les insectes
piqueurs sont des vecteurs de maladies
très efficaces ce pesticide est étendu
sur l'eau là où pondent les moustiques
et les mouches noires
il tue alors les larves de ces insectes
piqueurs avant qu’elles ne se transforme
en adulte
dans ce reportage de 2020 nous
présentions des études menées en Europe
qui démontreraient que le Bti tue aussi
d'autres insectes non pickers ceux-là et
qu'il pourrait avoir des impacts sur des
animaux qui vivent dans ou près des
écosystèmes traités
de cette quantité de biomasse dans
l'écosystème quelque chose va se
produire et ce n'est pas positif
toujours dans ce reportage nous
révélions qu'un document d'orientation
interne de l'ancien ministère de la
Faune du Québec datée de 2019 demandait
d'appliquer le principe de précaution
quant à l'utilisation du Bti lorsqu'il y
a un risque de dommage grave ou
irréversible l'absence de certitude
scientifique complète ne doit pas servir
de prétexte pour remettre à plus tard
l'adoption de mesures effectives visant
à prévenir une dégradation de
l'environnement
en d'autres termes le principe de
précaution c'est qu'il vaut mieux
prévenir que guérir et c'est ce qui a
convaincu la masse de Nicolet donc le
principe de précaution c'était aussi de
se dire on n'a pas toutes les réponses
moi je suis loin d'être une scientifique
mais est-ce qu'il y aura d'autres
réponses qui viendrontent qui vont nous
conforter dans notre décision ou qui
vont nous amener à prendre une autre
décision je le sais pas mais pour
l'instant le principe de précaution
c'était vraiment de ne pas prendre de
risques inutiles par rapport à des
réponses qu'on a pas grenouille des bois
crapaud d'Amérique là ça c'est super
au Québec des chercheurs sont justement
à l'oeuvre pour trouver des réponses
Langlois a mesuré l'impact du Bti sur
les amphibiens qui vivent dans nos
écosystèmes je pense que depuis les
dernières années on dit que les
amphibiens ou les grenouilles il y a pas
des faits il y a pas d'effet chez les
grenouilles ça fait rien fait là je
pense que là il faut changer
le verbe faut arrêter de dire ça il faut
dire qu'il y a des effets
avec son équipe elle a constaté en
laboratoire que le Bti ne tue pas le
crapaud d'Amérique et la grenouille des
bois mais ces animaux réagissent tout de
même de différentes façons à la présence
de ce pesticide dans leur environnement
étudier les intestins des deux espèces
de grenouilles et puis pour le crapaud
d'Amérique les données sont claires que
au STO qui a un traitement que ce soit
le Bti granulaire ou le Bti liquide les
deux types de Bti vont vraiment avoir
comme conséquence de changer la flore
microbienne de
nos crapauds d'Amérique
ce qu'on sait c'est que c'est important
la flore microbienne le microbiote pour
le système immunitaire faites là c'est
sûr que il pourrait par exemple avoir
une réponse différente au parasite par
exemple donc il pourra avoir une
difficulté de pouvoir
résister à d'autres stress
environnementaux encore là ça reste
hypothétique et c'est des questions qui
faudrait tester dans un deuxième temps
la chercheuse a aussi noté un changement
dans le temps de métamorphose
c'est-à-dire le temps que prenne les
amphibiens pour passer du stade de
têtard à celui de petites grenouilles
elle a également mesuré une réaction au
niveau de certains de leurs gènes en
présence de Bti
ça suggère que il y a un environnement
chimique il y a un environnement un
stress qui est soit cellulaire autour de
l'animal qui fait qu'elle essaie de se
détoxiquer d'éliminer un contaminant
quelconque de son organisme c'est
l'énergie aussi que la grenouille
utilise là qui est voué à se détoxiquer
au lieu d'être utilisé à d'autres
besoins physiologiques importants
au Canada 44% des espèces et
sous-espèces d'amphibiens sont
considérés comme étant en voie de
disparition ou menacées il faudra donc
d'autres recherches pour mieux
comprendre l'impact du Bti sur ses
animaux
[Musique]
mais pour Valérie Langlois leur des
choix à sonner c'est qu'elle risque
qu'on est prêt à
accepter comme population québécoise
est-ce qu'on est prêt à accepter le
risque il y a un effet
indirect du Bti chez nos populations de
d'amphibiens ou est-ce qu'on se dit on
tolère pas le risque qui est associé à
ces eaux à ses effets indirects
les effets qu'engendre le Bti chez les
amphibiens mérite qu'on applique déjà le
principe de précaution en particulier
lors des périodes sensibles comme au
moment de la reproduction et du
développement des œufs en de jeunes
grenouilles métamorphosées
le présentement ce qui est difficile je
pense c'est que c'est à chaque
municipalité du Québec à prendre la
décision si oui ou non ils vont utiliser
le Bti avec ou sans les connaissances
scientifiques requises pour prendre la
décision donc je pense que c'est ça un
petit peu qui est plus difficile
la question est posée est-ce que les
municipalités et le gouvernement du
Québec ont entre leurs mains toute
l'information scientifique nécessaire
pour faire les bons choix en matière
d'utilisation du bd
l'industrie croit que oui et que le
débat est clos mais notre enquête révèle
que la réalité est peut-être tout autre
le Québec va-t-il devenir un pionnier
dans le monde en instaurant le principe
de précaution dans le cas du Bti les
scientifiques le réclament mais
l'industrie ici oppose fermement et
comme vous allez le voir le lobby du Bti
a travaillé fort en coulisses pour
convaincre le gouvernement de maintenir
le statu quo
[Musique]
ici on est sur une des 40 fermes que
l'on suit en estimanté régie pour
mesurer le succès de nidification des
hirondelles bicolores
le chercheur marque bélile est inquiet
est-ce que le Bti a un impact mineur
dans nos écosystèmes tels que le suggère
l'industrie personnellement j'en doute
ce professeur à l'Université de
Sherbrooke s'intéresse aux oiseaux
insectivores dont plusieurs espèces sont
menacées
chez certaines populations les
scientifiques ont constaté des déclins
dramatiques de 40 à 60% depuis le début
des années 70
[Musique]
une des principales raisons qui explique
cette hécatombe c'est que le
garde-manger de ses oiseaux qui est
surtout constitué d'insectes est en
train de se vider
[Musique]
dans perspective que la biodiversité est
soumise à plusieurs facteurs de stress
l'utilisation de Bti va avoir un impact
sont moins certains ce que l'utilisation
est
nécessaire au Québec
ça au moins non à ce que je sache on n'a
pas de problème de santé publique
important par contre avec les
changements climatiques tout peut
arriver si on a de méchantes bestioles
qui débarque chez nous que les insectes
piquèrent deviennent des vecteurs bien
là peut-être on pourra considérer
l'utilisation du Bti mais dans le
contexte actuel le chercheur n'y va pas
par quatre chemins et demande à Québec
d’intervenir est-ce qu'on devrait user
du principe de précaution face à la
situation du Bti pour moi ça fait aucun
doute que oui
des scientifiques de l'ancien ministère
de la faune partage la vie des
chercheurs que nous avons rencontrés au
sujet du principe de précaution
tellement que leur position se retrouve
écrite noir sur blanc dans cette revue
de littérature scientifique de près de
200 pages l'accès à l'information nous a
permis de le confirmer à la lumière des
résultats de l'analyse de l'information
scientifique qui montre qu'il n'y a pas
toujours consensus et par principe de
précaution il est recommandé d'éviter ou
de minimiser les épandages surtout dans
les habitats essentiels des espèces
menacées et vulnérables ainsi que dans
les airs naturelles protégées cette
bible devait servir de cadre au décideur
sur la politique à adopter face aux
bêtises mais durant les deux dernières
années rien n'a bougé parce que l'étude
semble avoir été tablette
l'enjeu est de taille si le gouvernement
accepte d'appliquer le principe de
précaution le Québec deviendrait un
précurseur sur la planète en matière
d'encadrement du Bti impossible pour
l'industrie de laisser passer ça
pour lui venir en aide j'ai des g la
principale entreprise qui effectue des
traitements au Bti au Québec engager le
cabinet de relation publique nationale
au travers de leur démarche officielle
de lobbying ils ont tenté de convaincre
le gouvernement de faire marche arrière
et de retirer le principe de précaution
voici comment ça s'est passé
dès le 14 septembre 2020 le
sous-ministre à la faune Mario Gosselin
organise une rencontre entre son
ministère GDG et national une réunion
qui a plu à l'industrie monsieur
Gosselin mes collègues et moi vous
remercions pour l'excellente réunion de
cet après-midi je réitère notre offre à
l'effet de mettre à votre service une
expérience pratique de plus de 40 ans en
contrôle biologique et de participer
plus étroitement à l'appréciation des
études et de la nouvelle analyse
entourant l'usage du Bti
dans un courriel du 6 novembre 2020 GDG
explique ce qui devrait être retiré des
documents gouvernementaux les principaux
points ou les opinions divergent
grandement sont un le principe de
précaution il n'y a pas de risque grave
et irréversible alors pourquoi
maintenant une section sur le sujet
j'ai déjà rappel alors au ministère
l'importance des prochaines orientations
je suis désolé d'insister mais il faut
se rappeler que dans le contexte actuel
nous sommes tous à tenter de récupérer
une situation et de minimiser les torts
causés par le document de 2019 ce
prochain document d'orientation aura une
portée publique politique et économique
énorme
plus tard dans la journée un
représentant de national interpelle le
sous-ministre je crois comprendre que
les discussions ne vont pas du tout dans
le sens souhaité nous souhaitons avoir à
nouveau un entretien avec vous dans les
plus brefs délais
cinq jours plus tard le gouvernement
accepte de remettre à l'industrie une
partie sensible de l'étude celle sur le
principe de précaution afin d'obtenir
son avis nous avons l'autorisation de
vous transmettre la section pour obtenir
vos commentaires
déjà en décembre 2020 l'étude avait été
révisée par 10 scientifiques et semblait
à toute fin pratique prête à être
publiée
mais en avril 2021 l'industrie revient à
la charge nationale relance le
sous-ministre et lui demande de refaire
ses devoirs et de réaliser une deuxième
révision de l'étude par d'autres
scientifiques
bonjour monsieur Gosselin j'espère que
vous allez bien pourriez-vous me mettre
à jour sur vos intentions concernant
notre demande de révision de la revue de
la littérature sur le Bti effectué par
le mffp par des pères québécois
la réponse de Québec arrive le lendemain
matin
une révision des documents sera réalisé
revu de littérature et orientation nous
n'entendons donc pas diffuser ces
documents à court terme le temps que
cette révision soit réalisée
dans l'heure qui suit national
s'empresse de répondre aux sous-mains
merci
mais deux mois plus tard le dossier ne
semble pas prendre le chemin voulu par
GDG la compagnie s'adresse alors
directement au ministre je souhaite que
vous m'apportiez un éclairage sur une
situation difficilement compréhensible
et justifiable dont le théâtre est votre
ministère la revue de littérature
scientifique et les fonctionnaires sont
sévèrement critiqués ce document n'a ni
le titre ni l'impartialité d'une revue
de la littérature les auteurs d'énigrent
toutes les études en faveur du Bti et
cite les chercheurs associés à celles-ci
avec un manque flagrant d'éthique ne
donnant foi qu'aux études qui cadrent
avec leurs conviction et non avec la
neutralité de la science difficile
d'expliquer une telle attitude autrement
que par un parti pris idéologique et
pamphlétaire nous comptons sur vous
monsieur le ministre pour remettre de
l'ordre et de la cohérence dans ce
dossier
ce sont les derniers échanges auxquels
nous avons eu accès c'était en juin 2021
[Musique]
est-ce que les démarches de l'industrie
ont porté fruits
ce qui est clair aujourd'hui c'est que
la mise en place d'une nouvelle
politique québécoise quant à
l'utilisation du Bti a pris beaucoup de
retard début 2023 rien n'avait encore
bougé
nous avons voulu connaître la position
de GDG mais la compagnie a refusé de
nous accorder une entrevue c'est par
courriel qu'elle nous a répondu nos
intentions à l'égard des rencontres avec
le gouvernement était simplement
d'offrir un regard fondé sur de
nombreuses années d'expertise
opérationnelle adaptée au domaine
bioclimatique québécois et ce dans le
but d'approfondir et de parfaire la
maîtrise sur le sujet
cette notion nous avons demandé au
ministre de l'Environnement qui est
désormais responsable de la faune de
nous expliquer si les lobéisses de
l'industrie du Bti avaient réussi à
influencer le processus décisionnel
Benoît charrette a d'abord accepté de
répondre à nos questions avant de faire
volte-face
à quelques jours de la diffusion de ce
reportage nous avons appris que son
ministère va bientôt rendre publique la
revue de littérature scientifique et la
nouvelle orientation du Québec sur le
Bti bonne nouvelle pour les uns mauvaise
pour les autres le principe de
précaution il serait toujours présent
reste maintenant à voir comment il sera
appliqué sur le terrain
pendant ce temps un moratoire sur
l'utilisation du Bti a été demandée par
des groupes environnementaux les
résultats de cette étude vont dans le
même sens et le combat se poursuit dans
les conseils municipaux en Allemagne et
en Argentine par des compagnies
indépendantes maintenant c'est aussi aux
citoyens décider si on vit dans un monde
démocratique à Nicolet les élus ne
reculeront pas on sent qu'on travaille
dans le bon sens on sent qu'on travaille
pour les générations à venir parce que
c'est aussi ça faire de la politique
c'est d'avoir plus qu'une vision 4 ans
chez nous ce qu'on souhaite c'est de
laisser à nos enfants puis à nos
petits-enfants une biodiversité riche un
territoire intéressant protégé aussi une
eau potable de qualité une qualité de
vie exceptionnelle c'est vraiment ça qui
guide qui guide nos décisions même si
parfois ça peut avoir des impacts sur la
population actuelle qui doivent vivre
avec ces changements-là on est prêt à
assumer cette décision là
[Musique]